[Music]
andy welcome back to the show it's nice
to see you again yeah thanks tim good to
see you
i thought i would start with a little
revisitation to one takeaway from our
last conversation and for people who
didn't hear the first conversation i
want to recommend they do go back and
listen because we cover a lot of
biographical information and many
different nooks and crannies that we
won't cover this conversation but
there's one
which was the 478 breath that i believe
you learned from dr robert fulford who
was if i remember correctly in osteopath
am i getting that right correct yes do
you still use the 478 breath
well i do it myself regularly i do it a
number of times a day i teach it to
almost everyone i meet i teach it to all
the doctors i train i teach it to
patients but whenever i get the chance i
do it when i give talks i often end by
doing it i don't remember whether i told
you last time i was invited by the nsa
to come in and
this was a few years ago out of the blue
the nsa asked me if i would come and
talk to them about stress and how to
manage it i bet so it was an audience of
about a thousand and then it was
telecast to remote sites around the
world and i had them all doing the 478
breath which was very satisfying could
you recap just for folks
what the 478 breath is just the format
of it and then what it accomplishes
because i did it earlier today and and
found it to be such a rapid
state change mechanism
i had felt neglectful for not doing it
more often since our last conversation
but if you could just do a recap sure
first of all if people just will google
my name in 478 on youtube you'll find
videos of me doing it which gives
details and the last i looked there were
millions of of hits on that uh youtube
thing anyway the the basic technique is
to breathe quietly in through the nose
to a count of four hold the breath for a
count of seven and then forcibly blow
air out through the mouth for a count of
eight and repeat that for four breath
cycles when you're first learning it
eventually you can go up to eight breath
cycles but no more than that and to do
this religiously at least twice a day
and the real effects come after doing
this regularly for
oh four to six weeks and they're really
remarkable this is the most powerful
method i've found to access the
relaxation response
um to and it's the most powerful
anti-anxiety measure i've ever come
across
so let's let's talk about perhaps
another tool that people might associate
with
stress alleviation or at least some
people use it for that but
you were one of the earliest public
advocates of cannabis and advised
congress on early cannabis policy
and also
conducted and published human trials
with cannabis your personal relationship
to cannabis has changed over the decades
and i'd be curious to know
what your current use if any looks like
and for what purpose you use
cannabis yeah i don't use it at all tim
and i have not used it for probably
20 25 years and my relationships changed
so dramatically over the years in my 20s
late 20s early 30s it was a source of
great fun and pleasure and really
stimulated my creativity helped me write
then i think gradually it turned into
more of an introspective experience and
then somewhere in my late 30s early 40s
i really stopped getting useful effects
from it and i found it just made me
groggy and sedated and i kept using it
even though i wasn't getting any
valuable effects and finally stopped and
now you know i just haven't used in a
long time it has no interest for me
are there any particular
tools
that you use plants or otherwise for
writing i imagine you still do a fair
amount of writing is there anything that
has filled that gap for you
one is matcha green tea
and the other is coca leaf and uh as you
know i'm a great fan of of coca leaf and
i've worked for
many years to try to rehabilitate coca
to teach people the differences between
coca and cocaine and i'm delighted to
see finally after all this time there is
some momentum building around
legalizing coca making it available what
is that momentum if you could speak to
because i've had very limited exposure
to coca but it was given to me when i
suffered from altitude sickness in south
america and i mean literally within 45
minutes my symptoms had all but vanished
it was incredible to
experience the effects firsthand but
what momentum
what changes are you seeing in the
united states
well first of all there's a lot of
changes in colombia and in other
countries and in this country too there
are groups forming really working to
legalize coca to make it medically
available to make it available to people
to teach people the differences between
coke and cocaine one group that i've
been doing some work with that you may
know of is the river styx foundation
i do cody swift as director cody swift
and they're very interested in trying to
fund coca research to document some of
the medical benefits
but it's the first time in in
40 some years that i've seen any change
in attitudes up here and i think would
be a great thing for people to have
access to coca it's it's not cocaine it
has distinct effects it has unique
medical effects
we should have access to it not to
mention the fact that this is the sacred
plant of a great many indigenous people
in south america and it has been so
demonized by
our society and i think given all the
momentum around
looking at indigenous cultures and
rights that this also plays into this of
rehabilitating the sacred leaf
i agree with that 100 and i want to give
river six foundation
cody swift and his team also a nod for
their work with respect to an
organization called the indigenous
peyote conservation initiative ipci yeah
great which
purchased a tract of land
in texas so not too far from where i
live although texas is effectively a
country it's gigantic so don't
underestimate drive time
and uh it is it has become such a symbol
of hope
for so many
native american groups throughout the
united states including groups who
historically would not necessarily
automatically get along it's been this
unifying
sort of catalyzing project so i want to
give them a nod for that could you speak
to and explain the beneficial plants
research association well it's a
research foundation that i started in
1979
way ahead of its time
we had a stellar advisory board
including
dick schulte's albert hofmann
alexander shulgin
and i mean it was amazing advisory group
and the purpose of this
was to look at
plants that have been neglected or
unrecognized that could be of great
benefit up here
starting with coca was one of the main
ones but we looked at other kinds of
stimulants kava which at that time was
relatively unknown
so the idea was to get research going on
these to teach people about them and as
i say it was just way ahead of its time
so eventually
we folded but i'm really interested in
resurrecting this and a common interest
that of cody swift in mind
is looking at
at demonized plants
and my feeling has always been you know
a theme of my writing has been that
there are no good or bad drugs there are
just good and bad relationships with
drugs and i think you can broaden that
the plants as well
coca being a prime example we've said
that is a bad plant you know the source
of of all sorts of trouble but the
problem is how we've related to that
plant taking cocaine out of it and
making that available and i think if you
look at a there's a whole bunch of other
plants that we consider problematic and
it's really how we've related to them
that's the problem and i think it would
be interesting to try to rehabilitate
some just as an example things like
ephedra
and cot
opium poppies
tobacco even that it's our misuses of
these that have caused trouble it's not
the plan itself
i was going to mention the last tobacco
which i never thought in a million years
i would develop an interest in because i
grew up hating smoking and everything
related to cigarette smoking but
after spending more time in south
america and reading
books i'm going to get the title wrong
but it's something like tobacco and
shamanism in south america i think it's
johannes wilbur or johannes excellent
book very dense it's not light reading
for people who are looking for
something to snack on before bed it's
probably not the book
but
let me come back to one that you
mentioned and that is cava so
a friend of mine reached out to me
recently to get my two cents on a new a
new supplement that he is taking in
place of his evening cocktail
so he's decided he's in his 70s and has
decided to cut back on alcohol intake
because he sees how alcohol affects his
sleep using an aura ring and other
devices and he switched to this
supplement which contains two things
kratom
and kava
and i know very little about cava kratom
i have some thoughts on to be curious to
hear your thoughts on uh contains
mitrogyne seems to hit opiate receptors
so i believe there are people who
abuse kratom who have now developed
dependencies that are in rehab at least
i've heard some stories related to that
but i know far less about cava
would you mind elaborating on
kava
sure
cava is the major
uh psychoactive plant that's used in
oceania in many islands throughout the
pacific it's the
very large root of a large plant in the
black pepper family and it is
has unique chemistry in many of these
islands people make a beverage from it
originally by chewing the root and
spitting it into a bowl and mixing it
with water or coconut juice or now more
often drawing it and powdering it and
mixing it into a liquid and it is
functions as a social stimulant and
lubricant but it is a natural sedative
and calmative and probably the most
important anti-anxiety
natural product out there extremely
useful and and essentially no toxicity
and so
it does not interact with alcohol does
not interact with other sedatives
it's quite safe and i recommend it very
frequently to people
do you know what effect if any it has on
sleep quality
my friend has the subjective experience
of it helping him to wind down and go to
sleep but i wonder
what effect it has on sleep quality
because you look at some say sleep aids
like ambien and so on which help you to
fall asleep but they affect
the cycles of sleep and depth that's
putting it mildly you know all of these
all of these sleep understatements
whether over the counter or prescribed i
think are dangerous drugs first of all
they don't reproduce natural sleep all
of them suppress dreaming which is an
essential component of good sleep
they distort sleep architecture they're
addictive and they interfere with
cognitive function so i i think there's
really no justification for using them
unless
for very short-term use because of
situational insomnia but kava has none
of these ill effects it can be used long
term regularly i don't know that we have
good studies on how it affects sleep
quality but i don't know of any
indications that it has any of those
adverse effects that the
usual sleep aids do and i suppose i
should actually just go back to my
friend who is
granted tracking imperfectly but he's
tracking his sleep with the aura ring
that does capture some biometric data
that is sort of uh interpolated to
land on percentage of sleep as different
phases including rem and so on so i i
should actually just go back to him but
the problem tim is that he's using
kratom also which is a significant agent
and
we really would like to see this with
cava along what it does could you expand
on that please
well i i don't know that much about
kratom it's been used in
indonesia where it's native to help
people break opiate opioid dependence
and it it has sedative effects and
opioid-like effects i think there is a
downside to it uh and some concern about
people using it in not good ways but i'm
not an expert on kratom
i'll mention to folks who are interested
in perhaps learning a bit more about it
there's a good episode
of hamilton's pharmacopoeia
pharmacopoeia i never know how to
pronounce that second word
that covers
kratom and mitrogynine and
goes into the chemistry in the history
which and also environmental costs
depending on how these things are
harvested
which which i can recommend to folks
that can be found wherever you find your
finest videos amazon prime and other
places for sure
since i invoked the name of hamilton
morris i want to actually jump into a
separate episode of his where he he
attempts to identify
the first known use of bufo alvarius so
the sonoran desert toad yes i remember
that now his conclusion was that there's
no compelling evidence to suggest
indigenous use
and in fact the first documented use of
at least
smoking
the crystallized venom from the snare
desert toad was documented in 1989 by
this amateur chemist named ken nelson i
think it was right yeah are you aware of
other use of that species or other
species i know you've looked at this
well i think i'm one of the first people
to have smoked toad venom i did that
with wade davis and we wrote the first
scientific paper about bufo alvarius uh
you know we've
we have not been given much credit for
that but we really were the first people
to report on it scientifically and we
speculated that it was possible that
there was indigenous use of toad venom
for all sorts of suggestive reasons i
don't think there is any definitive
evidence of that you know i think this
graduate student published a paper in
which they identified 5-methoxy dmt
in the venom making this unique among
toads and some people read that and got
the idea of using toad venom and it
spread among
hippies in the southwest and that's
where i learned it from a a hippie
friend named white dog i think he's
mentioned in hamilton mars he was a
great character yeah and i had a
property in the desert that boarded on
saguaro national park and i was
surrounded by toads in the summer you
know they they're eating machines they
just eat insects all the time and i had
outdoor lights and they'd hop in the
house and these are huge animals they're
football sized and
you know i would pick them up they pee
on you as soon as you pick them up and
they're so strange looking and i
milked the venom and uh wade davis and i
smoked it and
amazing because this is the first known
occurrence of a psychedelic drug from an
animal source
so that was really you know that's
scientifically very interesting
now wade davis would you mind just
providing a snapshot of who way davis is
and why
you're firing
the beneficial plants research
association back up at this point in
time wade was a graduate student of
richard evan schulte's
some time after you know schulte's was
my mentor as an undergraduate at harvard
and then i had a very close association
with him at the harvard botanical museum
for many years so i got to know wade
when he was a graduate student you know
he's now a very well-known
anthropologist ethnobotanist prolific
writer and traveler and you know a good
friend very bright guy
and uh he like me is also very
interested in the coca project and works
with river styx
and my feeling is that as i said the
beneficial plant research association
was way ahead of its time but now i
think there is traction out there to
look at a lot of
there's so many plants yet to be
discovered that have beneficial effects
not just psychoactive ones but things
with medicinal effects stimulants
sedatives you know all sorts of things
that are potentially useful and i'm a
great believer in natural products and
think that in many ways many of them are
superior to synthetic
chemical drugs and i like to help people
know about them and i want to see
research on them and discover more of
these so i think it's time to try this
again
also for folks who may want to double
click on wade davis a couple of of notes
i believe it was one river that he wrote
which
chronicles much of
richard evan schulte's adventures who's
also considered in some respects the
sort of godfather
of
modern ethnobotany i suppose it'd be
fair to say yep and his name has come up
with
dr mark plotkin on this podcast before
so we've we've spent some time chatting
about richard evan schulte's also if
anyone who's watching if you're of my
vintage or older because the movie is a
little older has seen the serpent and
the rainbow yeah it's not a purely
factual account but still touches on the
investigation of zombification and
zombie
potions in haiti and is one of the
trippier
historical
investigations that you can
imagine i mean it's and that was made
from a book that was wade's first book
was the serpent in the rainbow yeah yeah
he's a very good writer very good
speaker has quite a few ted talks yeah i
think
can i tell you a schulte story yes
please so in my first year at harvard i
had to choose a major i had no idea what
i wanted to study because i was
interested in too many things i was
flipping through the harvard course
catalog and i came across this course
called plants and human affairs i mean
that was a strange name so to register
for this you had to go to the harvard
botanical museum
it was this old victorian brick building
and when i went in coming out of it was
the first long-haired man i'd ever seen
a proto-hippie this was in 1960 who was
probably up in the library which had the
greatest collection of books on
psychoactive plants so the schulte's
classroom
was decorated with blow guns from south
america and all sorts of artifacts from
his travels and
plants and human affairs was about
economic botany plants that are of
economic importance other than
ornamentals and it included sections on
food plants medicinal plants drug plants
and each week we had a laboratory in
which we tried things and
for instance there was a fruit of the
week that people would from all over the
world send him fruits which are in a
freezer and we get to try these exotic
things but then there was a lab on
making soap and one and making ink and
one on drug plants in which we tried
this really obscure stimulant plant from
south america called yoko that has the
highest percentage of caffeine of any
known plant i think it's the only
academic course i ever took in which i
learned things of practical value
it was fabulous and i really formed a
close connection with schulte's and
stayed associated with him for many
years after
all right let's let's stay on harvard
for a minute so
you and your history
weave into
science botany psychedelic history in so
many different ways but before we get to
that
in the course of trying to find novel
questions or topics to explore in this
conversation so as not to duplicate the
first so i came across
a note i think this is actually on
doctorwild.com
what's funny about turning 72 was this
blog post i'll just read a paragraph and
i'd love for you to expand on this i
also had a brief career at harvard as a
letter writing prankster i would procure
letterhead stationary from powerful
people and organizations by various
means and send prank letters to
self-important people who i thought
needed deflating fun but also dicey at
times and i had to give it up okay good
could you please
elaborate a bit on this we probably
shouldn't go into that but
i got i got very good at this and
as a result people would actually
commission me to write prank letters uh
and i and give me stationery i had i had
white house stationery i had i had mayor
of new york stationery i did terrible
things i had this gold embossed
stationary from the mayor of new york's
office
uh i had the president of princeton
university stationery and i i gave an
honorary degree to the mayor of new york
from princeton and invited him to come
speak at commencement for a while so
often i had no idea what the results of
these were you know that i yeah they
just sent them out there and i didn't
know what would happen so this is in the
days before photoshop how
did you have frank abagnale of catch me
if you can just
forging this stationary no
procure you got it yeah the real deal i
got some myself and i had agents who
would procure it for
me okay now agent this makes me think of
something i also dug up which was
your time as a let's call it a double
agent at the harvard lampoon and at the
harvard crimson is that am i getting
that right you are that's that was never
done these were rival organizations and
nobody had ever been on both at the same
time so that was a little uncomfortable
but it was made for some interesting
times
all right and for people wondering i
mean the harvard lampoon
is a
satire magazine that is produced i mean
conan o'brien
you go down the list i mean a long list
of famous comedians and writer producers
and so on including a few people who
have been on on this show and then the
crimson is the the school paper
uh i was doing some
searching just to see what has happened
in the last few years
with in terms of news coverage including
your name and i one came up
that
is related to let's just call it the
psychedelic renaissance as some people
have called it that we are
witnessing now and the headline is at
harvard psychedelic drugs tentative
renaissance and i'll just read the intro
and then i have a question so in the
early 1960s the harvard psilocybin
project made national headlines for its
unethical research methods and
controversial leader psychologist
timothy f leary a lot of people
recognize that name someone nixon called
the most dangerous man in america now 60
years after larry's departure harvard is
again part of the conversation around
the future of psychedelics from research
in the lab to conversations among the
student body psychedelics are making a
tentative yet undeniable renaissance on
campus a renaissance conscious of
harvard's checkered history with the
substances yet working to move beyond it
and so i found your name in here because
at the crimson you
you wrote about as i understand it leary
and who is then richard albert later
rahm das
could you
just describe
the coverage how that came about how you
relate to it now
what effect that had because that a huge
effect i mean it seemed to have a huge
impact on mainstream culture yeah well i
was the only i think member of the
crimson who had a science background and
i was majoring in biology so it felt i
was assigned
to be the writer about this controversy
as it developed
i met lyrian alpert in the early days
by the way i think the early research
they did was really terrific you know
they were the first people to really
emphasize sentence setting
as
really important determinants of drug
experiences they documented very
positive effects of psychedelic
experiences on prisoners
in conquered reformatory i mean really
interesting stuff and that was before
they started
you know a kind of cult grew up around
them the faculty got very upset and i
was the one who wrote stories about that
i have mixed feelings about that but
i've come to peace with it i made peace
with leary sometime
a few years after i graduated and uh
then ramdas
you know i knew over the years i
did fundraisers for him when he had a
stroke and a few years before he died i
had a really good meeting with him in
maui
and uh in which he said that i had done
him a blessing by forcing him out of
harvard because otherwise he wouldn't
have been ramdos
almost certainly true
and uh
it's worth folks who are familiar with
romney's going back and looking at the
early photos of of richard alpert quite
different very different look
at tim can i also say you know that
you're talking about this psychedelic
renaissance it astonishes me
the momentum and the mainstreaming of
this a few months ago town and country
magazine of all places had a major
article titled why is everyone smoking
toad venom in town and country magazine
that's wild yeah really seems like
something out of a south park episode
from a few years ago
so let's actually talk about the newest
chapters and i guess this is kind of a
two-part question so
if you're open to it you said you'd sort
of had mixed feelings and come to peace
with the early writing i'd love for you
to
just expand on that if you're willing to
and then from your
perspective and observation of what's
happening now
what you think people are paying too
much attention to or too little
attention to everywhere that i have gone
to speak in the past few years no matter
what topic i'm talking about whether
it's nutrition healthy aging integrative
medicine i get questions about
psychedelics you know people want to
know where they can access them
how they can have these experiences i
mean there is just a hunger out there
and uh i i find it amazing and i think
it's a very good thing happening in our
society maybe the you know one of the
only good things i see happening in our
society
and i think the more people who have
positive psychedelic experiences that
may lead to the change in consciousness
which i think is the only thing that can
turn things around for us
do you see people getting anything wrong
or
making mistakes
over emphasizing things anything that
you'd like to draw
attention to when you observe this given
your decades of observation in the space
i'm sure there are still plenty of
people who are using psychedelics just
as party drugs and recreational drugs
and i guess that's fine but i think they
miss out on the you know the real
potentials of these things
i think the medical profession
is really slow to look at how they can
make use of these drugs we're still
waiting to see them moved out of
schedule one and made legally available
there's a great need for people trained
and how to guide psychedelic experiences
there's an awful lot of circling around
of commercial interests looking at how
they can capitalize on all this so you
know a lot going on i don't know how
it'll all play out
just a sidebar this is this is not
intended to be a major branch in this
conversation but another
little-known fact to me at least is
something i found this is on psychedelic
review
in 1977 he that's you authored a
scientific article on the use of
hallucinogenic mushrooms in the pacific
northwest of the united states his study
of mushrooms inspired the name of a
psilocybin species or i guess it's
philosophy species discovered in 1995 i
don't know how to pronounce this
why lei there we go cilacity wiley i
how did this
come about well my good friend paul
stamets
who i've known for 40 some years
named that species for me you know it
you cannot name a species for yourself
in
botany science but you can name it for
someone else so he did that to honor me
i'm very honored there have been
attempts to knock the species off saying
it's not a legitimate name but it has
most recently been confirmed as a
separate species
this may be a boring question for almost
everybody listening but i'm curious
where does the naming convention come
from so i think of like uh is it lefra
williamsei or william
yeah
where you have the double i after the
name of the person who discovered it at
the end as the second component of the
species name do you know where that
naming convention comes from well i
think it goes back to linnaeus who was
the the really founder of modern
taxonomy
and there are international rules of
scientific nomenclature the names are
often put in latinate forms so williams
who
described that species it becomes
williams eye and
you know in the botanical name
okay that's just to satisfy my own
curiosity on that i also found a
mention of
your experience of dysthymia which
i believe is mild to moderate depression
yep
for much of your life emerging from it
only in my early 50s this is you
how did you emerge from it in your early
50s
i wrote a book called spontaneous
happiness which is about emotional
mental health and it really goes into
great detail about how to manage
depression anxiety
by with non-medication means
knowing that the medication is there if
you need it but for depression we have
tremendous evidence of the value of
physical activity both as a preventive
and as a treatment
tremendous evidence for the use of
supplemental omega-3 fatty acids
fish oil or fish
there's an enormous variety of
psychological methods
things like cognitive therapy which i
think are extremely useful
there's a whole range of spiritual
techniques that should be looked at
whether it's meditation mindfulness or
or even gratitude
there's
very interesting research showing that
just
the simple act of keeping a little
journal of things to be grateful for and
making a note of that as you go to bed
can improve mood for lasting effects for
a month
another
area of research that i find fascinating
is that moods are contagious
and you can track them through a
population just like you can track
movements of an infectious disease
if you live within a half mile of a
happy person that you know your chances
of being happy are increased by you know
a certain percentage and the effect
falls off with distance i mean
fascinating so you want to think about
who you associate with you know if
you're prone to depression and you hang
out with people who are depressed and
you watch sad movies and read sad books
and listen to sad music probably that's
going to worsen your depression i mean
simple stuff like that
when did you go to japan for the first
time
in 1959 in the fall of 1959 when i was
17 years old
how did you end up going to japan when
you were 17. i was a student in an
experimental school called the
international school of america this was
the first
year of its operation it took a group of
22 students and six faculty people
around the world for eight and a half
months oh man living with native
families it's incredible various
countries and our first stop out of the
us was japan and uh
i
can remember this distinctly flying on a
propeller plane from hawaii
to tokyo it was an endless flight that
must have taken a long long time hours
and arriving in tokyo on a cold rainy
morning on november 1st
taken to meet our host families they all
had sons majoring in english at ko
university
but it turned out they couldn't speak
any english so
i was then driven a great distance to
urawa city which is outside of tokyo
lived with this middle-class family
with almost no verbal communication
possible
but oddly
i felt at home in in that home and
i loved the food i loved everything i
really
felt i had past lives in japan i had
some deep connection with it how many
times have you been back since probably
50 i mean many times
now you've been to
okinawa
quite a number of times
and i've spent a little bit of time
there okinawa is considered a blue zone
right they have
in certain portions of okinawa
a population
that contains i guess the let's just
call the per capita highest percentage
of centenarians or something along those
lines
what are some of the lessons you've
taken away from that or observations
that you've made
well it's such a different world there
you know they live in a pacific paradise
with clean water and air they have an
unbelievably varied fascinating diet
very different from the japanese
diet
they get physical activity but one of
the things that most struck me
was the different attitude toward aging
in that society that old people are
valued as
national treasures efforts are made to
include them in all aspects of of social
life
very different from what you see here
you know where we like to isolate old
people with other old people and not
have to deal with them
one of the stories i collected over
there
is that a common cause of sibling
fighting in traditional okinawan society
is over who is going to get to take care
of the aging parents that's a little a
little different from what we see here
so i think that's extremely important i
took my my mother there when she was i
think 90
89 or 90 i was invited to give a talk
at a conference in okinawa and
they like to trot out their centenarians
at all events so there was a bunch of
them at an opening party and they would
all come up to my mother and say i'm
101. how old are you and she was very
embarrassed about her her age and i
think it was it was interesting to watch
her be in a culture where people were
proud of being old
so that's one of the lessons i learned
i spent
a bit of time i want to say
four four or five days in this village
called origimi yes i know okay yes
is sort of the creme de la creme of the
yes of the centenarian olympics and
every person i met who seemed to be
saying their 90s or 80s 90s or beyond i
would ask what's the secret and i got
back a different answer from just about
everybody i'm sure there were a few
things that closely line up with what
you're saying one was
old people were active i mean people
were out in the gardens people were
members of choral societies we had a
driver at the time for a couple of days
and he would say well i'm still young
i'm still a young whippersnapper
basically and he was in his mid 80s
and we drove by
a number of places where he would point
out you'd say that's where the old
people just sit inside watching
television that's the end
he's like that's when it's over and
it really seemed to be as you mentioned
the
nature of senior living in that area and
also the fact that they're
very engaged with community and very
very active i remember going to market
where they have the the purple tarot
which i'm sure yeah you've seen yeah and
uh as you mentioned the diet is very i
mean it's becoming more japanesized but
it's very different from what we
typically think of
as japanese food but i have to tell you
tim that in the over the period of time
that i was going to okinawa okinawan
longevity has plummeted especially among
men yeah and that's been attributed
entirely to the increasing consumption
of american fast food and i remember
there was an article in new york times
about that and they quoted a middle-aged
okinawan man who said the first time he
tasted a mcdonald's hamburger he thought
he had died and gone to heaven i mean
how could that how could that be i mean
these people have the most wonderful
food available but there you go in just
such a short space of time you can see
the effects of that
do you have an opinion on fermented
turmeric tea because i remember that was
ubiquitous i don't know if that's
perfectly stick or if it's something no
it's a very good thing it was drunk cold
unsweetened and it was very pleasant in
hot humid weather which is common there
and i was so taken with this that i
developed a relationship with the
company that's making the fermented
turmeric and began to import it
first as i had a ready-to-drink
product this was again probably way
ahead of its time but now through my
matcha company
machikari at matcha.com we sell
fermented turmeric the powder it makes
an instant drink i think this is a
first of all it's delicious and
refreshing i like it cold and
unsweetened and turmeric as you know is
the most powerful natural
anti-inflammatory agent and many health
benefits documented
lots of health benefits including as i
understand it there's some literature to
suggest
i don't i don't know if protection is
warranted but some mitigating effect
on
neurodegenerative disease like
alzheimer's disease and prevention of
cancer protection of liver function it's
got
wide ranging effects it's good to
include in the diet and
fermented turmeric tea is an easy way to
do that
so why matcha because i've had matcha i
love matcha
why decide to dedicate
your energy
to
matcha at least in part well let me say
on the second day that i was in japan
back in
in november of 1959 my host mother took
me next door to meet her neighbor who
was a tea ceremony practitioner so the
three of us sat around and this woman
did a tea ceremony and presented me with
a bowl of matcha and i was completely
taken by it first by the color uh also
by the chasse and the whisk which i just
thought was marvelous and the taste of
it i fell in love with it so
i began
when i began going to japan more
regularly in the 1970s every time i was
there i'd bring matcha back to the
states and turn people on to it nobody
had ever heard of it here
and i just thought this was a great
thing to make available before i knew
anything about its health benefits and i
partnered with a matcha company in japan
and
began selling it through my website
again like the beneficial plant
association way ahead of its time
this was in the 1980s
and uh
you know i just always thought this
would be a great thing here so when i
had the chance
when i saw matcha becoming popular here
it bothered me that so few people had
access to good matcha because if if
matcha is not
prepared correctly and if it's not
stored correctly it oxidizes very
quickly because it has such a huge
surface area and it turns it loses that
bright green color it loses the good
flavor has a bitter taste and many
people here never tasted really good
matcha so i was determined to make that
available and that's why i started this
company and we got the great coup was
getting the url matcha.com people in
japan can't believe that we got that but
there it is
let's discuss the health benefits and
let me also just ask a question for
myself i would imagine most people
who listen to this and have had tea
before they imagine
tea leaves or a tea bag put into water
you steep and then you remove the tea
leaves and you're left with this colored
water and that is what you drink
but
matcha is
if if i'm understanding correctly whole
leaf
so if it would there would also be an
incredible importance or you could place
incredible importance on
quality or sourcing in so much as
if you're consuming whole leaf
tea that has been exposed to pesticides
you're going to be getting a much higher
toxin load as well is that am i thinking
about that correctly you are and there
is organic matcha available but not
nearly as in great supply as
conventional matcha
but we've monitored matcha for pesticide
levels and are assured that this is not
not a problem but the way match has
grown
how it's prepared
it's a long labor-intensive process and
much is the only form of tea
in which the whole leaf is consumed as
you say
i think we have the most research on the
health benefits of green tea in general
and there are many forms of green tea
that i like but matcha has the highest
level of antioxidants and of l-theanine
the calming amino acid that modifies the
effects of caffeine so it's unique in
that regard and i think there are
health benefits of matcha that are
distinctive among all forms of tea
how does l-theanine modify the
effects of
caffeine i think it it takes the jittery
edge off of caffeine i think the effects
of caffeine and tea and then coffee are
very different coffee produces i think a
jangling effect in many people there's
often a crash after a period of
stimulation
many coffee drinkers are physically
addicted to it and have a withdrawal
syndrome when they stop you don't see
anything like that with with tea and i
think some of that is because the
l-theanine has a calming effect that
that changes the effect of caffeine and
as i say matcha has more l-theanine in
it than any other form of tea
why is that is it that it's contained in
some of the fibrous
components of the leaf that are
discarded when it's prepared no i think
it has to do with the way the tea is
grown because what's unique about matcha
is that about three weeks before harvest
the plants are heavily shaded
with
shade cloth that cuts out about seventy
eighty percent of the sunlight and in
response to that the leaves grow
bigger and thinner and produce higher
amounts of antioxidants and l-theanine
so i think that's very unique there's
some the same shading process is used to
make a very high quality brewed green
tea called jokuro that i'm sure you're
familiar with that's quite delicious so
that also has these high levels
that's fascinating to me so it almost
seems like an adaptive stress response
by the plant to fortify itself well it's
trying to get it makes more leaf surface
in an effort to get more you know light
exposure and it develops more
chlorophyll which accounts for the
bright
color of matcha so i don't know how the
japanese discovered this shading process
but it is unique
and for people who have not seen even if
you never have matcha i certainly would
suggest that you consider it but even if
you're never going to drink matcha
go find
photographs of
exceptionally good matcha the color
is unlike anything else you have ever
seen in your life it is like a
phosphorescent almost a phosphorescent
green and i'm biased because green is my
favorite color oh good
it really is it really is something
something special can i say that uh
machikari i think has some of the finest
matcha available we're very particular
about our sourcing and listeners to your
podcast can get a generous discount if
they use the code tim
that's a listener exclusive folks so
there you go tim and that's easy to
remember matcha.com m-a-t-c-h-a-dot-com
and we can come back to this but you
mentioned your mom
and if my research is accurate she lived
until 94 is that right 93 93 so that is
still
it may not be a world record in ogamia
but that's still
quite a long lifespan
all things considered is that true on
both sides of your family no my father
died at 80 had cardiovascular disease so
my mother was much healthier and until
her last year she was quite active and i
think in pretty pretty good shape i
traveled with her a lot
it was fun to take her to japan and
other places
one of the things
i think her part of her philosophy that
may have contributed to this she said
it's very important never to lose your
sense of humor she said you always have
to be able to see the ridiculous side of
life
now is is that something that she
cultivated
in you as well or did she just encourage
it was there a form of play that helped
to weave that into your
being your kind of coding so to speak we
love to laugh together i mean i have a
lot of pleasant memories of that and i
think the
main thing that she did and my dad did
too was to encourage my curiosity
you know i've always been a very curious
inquisitive person and i think they
worried about me a lot in some of my
experimentation and wanderings but
they always said that i should follow my
passion and
they encouraged me to be curious
what did they think of i don't know how
much of a window they had into this but
your fascination with not just botany
and plants but also psychoactive those
plants those plants so just i'll tell
you one thing i remember this must have
been when i was in
after i was out of medical school but i
remember going to
to visit them in their apartment and
they were living in new jersey at that
time and my mother never said anything
to me but she'd leave newspaper
clippings by my bed about marijuana
causing brain damage
this was in our first conversation and
please tell me if i'm screwing this up
but i believe the the very first time
that you took mescaline your mom called
and said i hope you're not doing
something stupid like taking mescaline
like oh god
she had mom intuition and a telepathy
for sure
i could see that putting a bit of
english on your experience of mezcal i
did once they visited me in arizona this
must have been in the
1970s and i had coca leaves that i
brought back from south america and we
all chewed coca leaves together so they
they were acted as if they were very it
was a very daring thing they got quite
silly it was fun to do so how did they
feel my experience of coca chewing or
tea is that it's it's pleasantly mild
but it is far milder to me than a strong
cup of coffee let's just say what was
their experience like i think they
probably had minimal effect i think it
was more their their expectations and
than anything pharmacological
how old are you now andy i turned 80 on
june 1st
happy belated birthday thank you but i
have to tell you i have a very good
friend a cardiologist who says the same
age as me who said that his mother
always told him
joe don't get old you won't like it
[Laughter]
how do you relate to
getting older i mean you look you look
great for 80 certainly i mean i hope i
hope i look as good i already lost i
lost the hair early so i passed that
rubicon thankfully by the way the
meaning of philosophy it's a greek word
is boldhead so
i did not know that that's incredible so
philosophy widely i is pretty good
anyway cognitively i don't feel any
different i mean i really don't feel any
different from the way i felt when i was
in my 20s but i really feel changes in
my body especially especially
musculoskeletal changes you know
annoyances that i didn't have before i
think my sleep has changed
but
you know i think watching the body
change and
it's inevitable deterioration i think
that's an important thing to look at
and do you have any
plans for how you'll spend say the next
five years do you have certainly you
have this this matcha project which i'm
glad you're bringing to the world
because i just selfishly want high
quality matcha i love it i love matcha
but
in addition to that do you do you think
about projects you want to do kind of
longitudinally over
a period of time i don't feel compelled
to do anything i don't have the drive
that i did when i was younger
like i don't feel like i want to write
anything else i've written everything i
have to say yeah i want to see
integrative medicine really get on a
solid footing and become no really
mainstream which it's poised to do
i feel very deprived of travel during
these pandemic years and i want to make
up for some of that i'm going to japan
next month and that'll be
i'm really looking forward to that so
i'd like to get some travel in while i
can
yeah well you know our mutual friend
kevin rose also uh japanophile
and it would be fun it would be fun to
actually meet up at some point in japan
i mean yes i've certainly been quite a
few times i'm still in touch very close
touch with my
host mother who i lived with when i was
15 years old so we're still
still close and
that would just be a blast well i'm
creating this place for you to stay in
norikura kogan so
i expect you both to come oh yeah i can
give you the green light the thumbs up
on that without good without any problem
well
andy is there anything else that you
would like to
mention
today in this conversation or explore
people can find matakari
on instagram at machakari
m-a-t-c-h-a-k-a-r-i
the website is matcha.com they can find
you on twitter dr weil and dr wild.com
and we'll put all these in the show
notes yeah i'd also urge people to look
at the website of the center for
integrative medicine
now the andrew weil center for
integrative medicine which is hard for
me to say but it's uh
integrativemedicine.arizona.edu
great and look at the range of our
activities and educational programs some
of which are available to the general
public and are very good
andy it's uh it's always nice to see you
we'll link to all these things in the
show notes
anything that you would like to see
researchers
in the
realm of psychedelic science
focus more on or consider focusing on
yeah yeah yeah you know i i am somewhat
discouraged to see all the emphasis on
mental emotional health because i think
there's such tremendous potential for
psychedelic experience in physical
medicine for really changing the course
of chronic disease
for really affecting how people
experience their bodies you know i've
just seen so many dramatic effects of
psychedelic experiences on people who've
had chronic illness and i want to see
more exploration of that
and for a tasting of of some of that
people can listen to the first
conversation where we talk about your
experience with cat allergies yeah which
is
also just one of those head scratchers
that is uh sort of worth
digging into well there's a lot of stuff
like that out there and we want to take
it seriously and look how we can make
use of it
there's a book called the fellowship of
the river i think i'm getting that right
about a western trained
physician who ends up engaging very
heavily with
ayahuasca specifically and
in that account
talks about how certain things respond
or don't respond or i should say rather
appear to respond or don't respond more
often
than
other conditions let's just say and some
that seem to respond well and this is
not medical advice i'm not encouraging
people to go to the amazon and drink
ayahuasca
speak to your gp first uh but
are many of the autoimmune diseases ibs
crohn's disease etc that'd be top of my
list of things to explore the usual uses
of psychedelics in
so do you think
that is then not necessarily a physical
response to ayahuasca specifically with
its harming and everything else in the
vine
or or the dmt necessarily was something
that could be observed with
say psilocybin yeah i do i think it's
hard to disentangle all that but i think
that it's i don't think it's specific to
those chemicals yeah well it's a brave
new world there's certainly a lot of
research being done even more companies
being formed
and
i suppose it will be ultimately survival
of the fittest and survival of the most
interesting from a scientific
perspective so i'm cautiously optimistic
but
you've been
in this space for many many decades now
is there anything left for you to
experience personally within the realm
of of psychedelics or do you feel like
you've scratched that itch sufficiently
you know uh my first book the natural
mind alan watts wrote a blurb for it
which was great that's a good blurb and
the last line of it was you know when
you get the message hang up the
telephone yeah and i feel that way i
think i've gotten the message about
psychedelics i don't feel the need to do
further experimentation yeah well you
get the message hang up the phone and
let me just mention a few places where
people can find you i already did but
we'll we'll link to the center for
integrative medicine which is
integrativemedicine.arizona.edu is that
right
and then
certainly you can just search
andrew weil or dr weil and then the
platform of choice and it'll pop right
up and they can find you at dr weil
w-e-i-l-dot-com and
certainly can find the machakari at
is there anything else andy that you'd
like to add no that was a wide-ranging
conversation which i have enjoyed
greatly
thank you for taking the time andy
and to everybody listening until next
time be a little kinder than is
necessary to your fellow humans fellow
animals i suppose we could throw plants
in there as well let's not get too
ambitious
and as always until next time thanks for
tuning in
you